[Music]
we begin tonight with Demi Lovato's
confession about her ongoing battle with
substance abuse the singer is
apologizing for relapsing after years of
sobriety I wasn't ready to get sober I
was sneaking at in bathrooms sneaking it
throughout the night
nobody knew alcohol we're told that's
the source of Jimmy's downfall and one
of her many demons which in the past
also included cocaine cutting and Benji
I'm not so anymore Dimmie herself opened
up about what she calls my truth
releasing her new song sober today a
source tells ET her song is intense but
that's how she deals demi has to be
brutally honest and put it out there so
that she's not burdened with holding on
to her struggles privately
[Music]
we're told the relapse happened sometime
between April and May when Demi was on
break from her tour and while we don't
know whether she's currently back in
treatment the 25 year old former Disney
star has been acting more provocatively
lately posting shots of her touching
tongues with her backup dancer and doing
very suggestive dance moves on stage
earlier this month she canceled two
shows due to swollen vocal cords I'll
still struggle with past behaviors kind
of and cravings creeping in last week
Dimmie also revealed she's been body
shamed online after she gained a couple
pounds since giving up dieting in
January but you know what we give props
to Demi for being so honest about all
her struggles sorry not sorry there's a
drive that I have to stay sober because
I know that my life depends on it
[Music]